I
welcome to our I guess this is our first
research conference for the new school
year we have a great speaker come here
from DC Patricia mctaggart is a lead
research scientist from George
Washington University where she
instructs graduate students in health
information technology policy quality
and state health policy Patricia has
been a public servant for almost 30
years serving is in the Minnesota
Medicaid director director performance
Medicaid and senior advisor Medicare for
hikmah and CMS she provides technical
assistance to states and federal
agencies regarding health information
technology quality and Medicaid chip for
all aspects of health including
long-term care payment and service
delivery she is a member of any HC AHIMA
foundation hymns and CA boards and
serves on public policy advisory
committees for a high March of Dimes
Marco hie k him and is on the ONC
consumer engagement the employment task
force Wow I have an eclectic background
so she is here to tell us about it
health information insurance exchange
well I'm going to talk a little bit
about el all of the pieces that's what
thank you thank you oh you can tell kind
of my mind by background that I dabbled
in a lot of different pieces but the
pieces all fit together and I did a
presentation at Hema for the leadership
in the education that one of your peers
saw and asked if I would come speak to
you guys the way I want to do the
presentation though is if you hit a
slide and I say something that doesn't
make sense to you stop me and ask me or
if there's something that's interest
let's talk about it we don't need to do
presentation and then questions and
answers because we're going to hit a lot
of different things and basically calls
into three things one the environment
nationally and locally is changing
around you
and how some of the things that are
changing around you that affect both
what you can do research on and
opportunities to do research the other
pieces you've got a lot going on locally
to try and talk a little bit about some
of those things so you can at least hear
an outsider's perspective on some of the
cool things that are going on in Oregon
and you can ask me about that and last
but not least but and probably just as
important is a little bit of my
perspective on how your real life is
changing that we have moved from a world
of real grants and if you have a really
great idea somebody can fund it and I
don't think that's true anymore I think
we're in a contract world I think we're
in a world where unless you provide
value to them it's kind of what I've
said all along to even my grad students
if some you have to take a look at
what's out there and figure out if
there's a piece in it that's of interest
to you and then try and refrain what you
want to do in context of what they want
to get done because if you don't you're
not gonna be able to sell what you want
to do so the changes that impact your
policy and your leadership role to talk
about that just from a little bit and I
am a wonder or so if I wandered too much
now you can bring me back for doing it
one is the environment um we really as I
said are transforming healthcare and
those transformations in healthcare are
changing the demands for health care
administration and healthcare service
delivery as those transform their
dependent on and create the need for
more health information technology and
all of those create the demand for more
analytics and use of data this is not
about health information technology for
the sake of health of moon shun
technology nobody really cares about
that I was actually at a meeting last
week here where the guy said I don't
want to build the car I just want to
drive it so they don't want to know
about the technology they want to know
about the informatics and they want to
know that there's actionable information
that will come from valid data that they
can use and as close to real time as
absolutely possible so that whole
environment is changing the demands on
you and on the industry as well and how
we really try and be more effective and
more efficient it also changes how we
are seen as researchers I think
researchers now have a responsibility to
do things much more real time which is
really frustration for researchers
because people want answers yesterday
and the idea that I used to do 1115
waivers both of the federal government
and as Medicaid and you guys have a
little 15 waiver the concept was
originally I would authorize use the
federal government you would do
something for five years you would have
some good things and some bad things but
at the end of the five years you would
then do a great big evaluation and tell
me why it was successful or not right
now six months into it they want to know
you the incremental successes what's
working what's not working people can't
be at risk for five years the consumers
and the constituents so the whole idea
of being able to do incremental kinds of
answers is absolutely critical and
knowing the questions that need to be
answered initially day one the questions
that need to be answered along the way
and the questions that need to be
answered at the end and it kind of falls
into I talked about it in the world of
managed care before i do a contract with
you i need to know the quality standards
that you at least have the potential if
you don't have a network I'm not
contracting with you because there's no
way you can serve my clientele but that
doesn't guarantee you're actually going
to serve them so then I due process
measures that basically say are you at
least doing the things i would expect
you to do that would lead to the
potential good outcomes and that's kind
of what you do on the interim and then
at the end we really want to care if
people got healthy so those are the
outcome measures but nobody's going to
wait for us to do the outcomes of any
research project right now without being
able to answer something in between
people are also looking to you to bring
that validity and that credibility you
have the expertise in informatics in
ways nobody has most people have been
scared of it their entire lives they
thought of it as technical and there
aren't enough of you so the good news is
there's full employment because there
are so few in such a huge demand but as
a result of that you've got to be able
to translate what you're thinking and
doing into an environment that doesn't I
don't say they don't have a clue but
it's not their world so even the
terminology ends up being a very big
difference informatics I've heard people
say don't tell me what is it informatics
it's kind of like we now have new CM
clinical medical officers we used to
have CIOs and hospitals everybody kind
of knew what a CIO right does everybody
know what a CMOS hospitals decided the
cios didn't really know about healthcare
delivery so they wanted a clinical
perspective a medical perspective so
they created a new position that is now
a CMO which is a clinical medical
officer but it's a CIO with a medical
hat it's it's blending those two for
doing it my point in that is the
positions are changing the terminology
are changing and the need to be very
clear it is could never be understated
you know we used to say government has
too many acronyms IT has too many
acronyms and neither world uses the same
acronyms the same way so being very
clear and being able to lead and provide
that expertise is really another change
and a focus on a focus can't be on
research about what we have today
because the only thing we agree on is
that nobody likes the way it works today
and if you think about research by the
time your research is done we will have
changed the environment at least once if
not twice so how do you evolve the
research so you're researching to where
the ball is going and you know the joke
about where the hockey puck is going to
hit the hockey puck not where I'm
starting from but where it's going to
land that's what people want you to be
focusing on it still means you have to
know day one things but think about that
if you've got a three-year project in
Oregon you will have moved from the
Medicaid program and its traditional
managed care to a whole coordinated care
organization model that is more of a
service delivery system that integrates
housing and social services things that
we're not even assumed to be a part of
healthcare now if it affects health care
its healthcare those two things are
changing at the same time they're going
to integrate the private market and at
the same time we you have just gone live
with your health insurance marketplace
which we call two months ago the health
insurance exchange it's now the health
insurance marketplace so even the
terminology is changing as we go for
doing it so if you want to be relevant
if it's not analyzing what's going on
now it
except how it's transforming the world
that we're living in because it won't be
around anyway for doing it what makes
this double heart is why you're doing
this we're going to do continual changes
on my favorite one is everybody knows
icd-10 is going in-play right everybody
knows what icd-10 is right you're one of
the few groups that that you can
actually be able to yeses for doing it
it will change all the claims data for
doing it so being able to take that into
account is something you are aware of
but the people that I ask you the
questions that are going to even some of
the funders have no idea of the impact
on that so you have to be that
leadership role of explaining that and
then being very external it's what
others need of us rather than what we
need of others on there is not enough
money the end in DC right now with
everything closed down I can guarantee
you there's no money and how that
affects your current Krantz is also true
but the one methodology and i would say
message that is becoming out of the
federal government for a very long time
is that they have to have accountability
and they can't do grants anymore even if
they call them a grant they're not
really a grant there are a contract for
something they need done any questions
or comments about anything so far the
action yeah
we work for a few of the federal
agencies and some of them do issue
specific contracts and sometimes more
often it's grants are you suggesting
that many of the federal agencies will
move to contracts there's a big push to
make federal agencies move to contracts
even if it's called a grant as I said
even if it's called a grant it will feel
like look like more in my mind and this
is a terminology thing and a lot of
grants it was you had a great idea and I
give you grant and you could kind of
figure it out even arc basically they
would give you a grant because you sold
them on an idea and you would figure it
out and come back with results and all
they were really interested in was the
results on the timetable for doing it
not anymore their contract managers I
called contract managers their grant
managers are now being trained and
required to say what are you getting
incrementally for doing it it's not
about what they have the best idea we're
putting frames take a look at what they
are now they're putting frames about
it's not open engineering it's how am I
going to answer this question and are
you interested in helping me answer this
question so again it may be grants it
may be contracts but it still feels like
a contract and foundations you know
there used to be Robert Johnson
foundations I'm just picking on them I
don't mean to that you've got a grant
multi-million dollars for five years a
lot of those five year one's got notices
at three years and two years that
they've changed the priorities and that
they're done you've got notice and
they're moving on to the new issue of
the day because the issues that were
five years ago we're not the issues of
today so in the world of healthcare and
this is my newest grandson don't we all
do that for Dana but it's really what's
most important about health care it's
the most personal thing that we can deal
with so if you think about health care
it really is about building the system's
transformed around consumer centric
we've talked consumer-centric for a very
long time now we have kind of walk the
walk and make a consumer century and
really if you're going to do that
there's three things that can be looked
at it's the population
services are going to be provided and
what you're going to pay for them and
how you're going to deliver them there
are really only those variables for
doing it but the question is where they
play in relationship to each other
because the pot of money doesn't get any
bigger and you have to figure out how
the things are working so when the issue
is how do you actually deal with those
three variables and the real
transformation that's going on in health
care right now is taking a look at all
three components not just one now the
world of just dealing with hospitals is
gone it is a world about service
delivery to the consumer and if you
start at the left what people are
dealing with right now is a very
evolving policy while you're doing your
research we're going to change the
policy on top of it but policy is just a
concept if you don't have the
infrastructure and the service delivery
system in order to implement it in play
and they know what they're supposed to
do which means we're changing workflow
as you move as you know is we move to
the world of electronic health it's not
about just the use of a health
information technology get rid of paper
it's changing and creating efficiencies
and that creates differences in workflow
and that workflow has multiple
implications and all of those things are
happening simultaneously so being able
to do a cause-and-effect just quite
frankly is going to be near impossible
to do anymore because four by eight
variables are changing at once and then
as all of those things were trying to
put what was really the finance on
quality impact of any decision for doing
it and what you're going to see in the
year of 2014 it is probably the biggest
year if you think back a couple years we
change three major pieces of federal
legislation in less than two years we do
major pieces of federal legislation in
healthcare belt once every two years but
we did three in less than two years they
are all being implemented as we speak so
it's not just about health information
exchanges it is not just about health
insurance exchanges it's about Medicaid
eligibility changes it's about payment
reform all of the variables all
happening at once with a consumer in the
middle and people's expectation that
it's not talked but it's real walk for
doing it and every time we move one we
change all the rest for doing it so it
is it is not sequential it's
simultaneously
this is really my definition it is the
dependency and actionable information
which is dependent on accurate data at
the appropriate time which is dependent
on adequate health IT from the outside
world then we want to know about the
back they just want the transformation
and they want the actionable information
what we care about is making the first
the bottom pieces be accurate so you can
do the top pieces for doing it easier
said than done so my main message to do
is you have to think about tomorrow care
not yesterday air out which is a new
terminology but it even today care is
yesterday care for doing it because we
are moving away from it this is another
one of love my grandson in the middle
but this is a variation on a action
Oregon picture for doing it which is
really talking about state innovation
models because simultaneously to the
health insurance exchanges one of the
things that is going on in Oregon and
some other states are sim grants you
guys know what state innovative grants
are that your state has one like 40
million plus dollars of federal dollars
to do a transformation on the service
delivery of healthcare in the state of
Oregon your health insurance exchange is
adding two populations your Medicaid
expansion is having Medicaid populations
and you're building a health information
exchange structure simultaneous to this
which has a whole new initiative going
around but why you're doing this you've
also got a grant called a grant but it's
really a contract with the federal
government to move to a coordinated care
organization so is everybody know what
you're coordinated court care
organizations are you guys so the
regional base and they're like the old
managed care plans except they're not
because they are consumer centric and
they actually have local community the
hospital to clinics if you think of the
the old ways of looking at an HMO the
insurance company contracted with a
network in the new model the network
contracts with an administrative arm so
it kind of flipped for doing it and it
also changed another piece not only is
it regional and local base it changed
the definition of health care that it
really is anything that impacts health
is in although you kind of hell
term care out to the side because you do
that differently for doing it but the
point of doing this is in order to do
this transformation there are certain
goals that nationwide people are doing
but clearly you're trying to do here the
Triple Aim guys know that better health
lower cost better care that's the one
everybody talks about but in order to do
that we are really looking at
alternative payment models we're looking
at accountability a care coordination
performance reporting huge piece of
being able to do accountability and
innovative service delivery models in
order to do that it is data and
information dependent we are going from
structures were unlike Kaiser where
everybody works in one organization to
virtual teams virtual care coordinated
teams of players that didn't even used
to talk to each other behavioral health
with physical health dental is a part of
the physical health in order to do that
you have the middle circle which is
really the a chai tea foundati it is
that information highway you can call it
lots of things but it's the
infrastructure to make the data flow it
has to be there it's but health
information technology is not just
clinical information it's an enrollment
and eligibility it's a member portal its
identity management it is analytics
which is huge and its registration
repositories I think there's a tendency
in the world right now to talk about
electronic health records everybody's
clear about electronic health records
right do you guys think there's a
difference between electronic medical
record and electronic health record yeah
I like the summers idea either some of
you that are a little confused because
if you talk to vendors it's really hard
they use the terms here's the big
message in the world of Meaningful Use
guys know Matt meaningful uses right
meaningful uses money to hospitals and
providers for the use the meaningful use
of electronic health records it is
called an electronic health record
because an electronic medical record
communicates within the facility
electronic health record has to go
between facilities provider and hospital
hospitals and hospitals it is not a soul
within the system for doing it and
that's what the money is for because the
care team
care team in a hospital clearly needs to
work together but they've got systems to
do that it's a care team of the to avoid
readmitted to the hospital you don't
avoid readmit by the hospital doing it
they can only take it so far to make it
further you're not discharged too soon
that you've got really discharge
planning and that there's a good
transition of care which is a lot of
emphasis right now about transitions of
care but if there's nobody to transition
to or that information doesn't go to
somebody or they don't do anything with
it the hospital gets ding on the
hospital readmit so this real need for
all the players all of us and has
changed because of financial incentives
to really have all those players and you
can't do that by paper you can't do that
by fax and you certainly can't do it by
people in the old days if we did a
referral we would call somebody we would
know and stick it in Federal Express or
maybe fax it to both sexes you don't
really know if anybody ever picked it up
and if they picked it up if the right
person picked it up now think of
electronic and you guys know this and
the only world of informatics that it's
an electronic mail box is what it is but
it's getting people to go to their
electronic mail box and to use the data
and have it consumable because none of
us like a bunch of PDFs we have can't
really do anything with PDF we can read
it but we can't really utilize it so if
you think of your role and what the
world of health information technology
and you can't do the outside without you
being on the inside but the outside
folks don't want to worry about you they
want you to be like I want my computer
when I open it up or my iPad I just want
it to work I want it to get me there I
don't want to worry about what you know
portals that I have to go to like Google
and it gets me where I need to go that's
what they want from the outside world as
well the other thing that is happening
that we also need to be conscious of
because it's going to affect your world
is as we transform payment reform all
those data sources that you used to have
good news is gonna be some data sources
you didn't have before but some of those
that you've dependent on go away and
that makes it harder we have new
terminology I talk a little bit about
that my favorite one is only Congress
would in one year passed two pieces of
legislations that
have hie zin them and not even
understand that they did it but we have
solved that temporarily think about that
we had to hie s their solution was to
make one health information exchange in
hie and health insurance change and h IX
clearly that didn't work for people
because they were still too close to
looking the same so they decided to make
it health insurance marketplace which is
totally confusing people because they
don't know how that fits to the exchange
as we've lost that but my point is
acronyms are changing terms are changing
you're just going to have to be really
clear and what they are but they all
become new data sources for you we
didn't have a health insurance exchange
before so we didn't have data on the
uninsured we did because they were
uninsured we now have dated because
they're going to be insured think about
operating a health insurance exchange in
order to operate that they have to have
demographics they have to race and
ethnicity they have to have your
insurance they need to know what
qualified health plan you've chose it
they need to know your family because
it's a family coverage policy for doing
that and they have to know everything
that I need to know from Medicaid
because it has to be a simplified
application guarantees consistency
because it's one application or one
standardized way of data elements
standardized definitions standardized
times of collecting standardized
processes for processing them all new
opportunities that you can now bring in
for looking at something across
populations across payer sources so
that's a good news and they also connect
to the feds which is creates a whole new
set of things for doing it that created
a new populations like the immature now
became insured and new service delivery
models the whole tax credit capability
means that we're going to have more
information that is more internal
revenue based now there's all kinds of
restrictions and requirements on IRS
data that the health insurance exchanges
have to follow but it is again a new
data sources because in order to operate
those health insurance exchanges are
trying to connect to workman's comp
they're connecting to unemployment those
data sources were never connected before
they were all isolated so the
opportunity over the next few years
because of what they're creating for
operations create a new opportunity for
things for evaluation and for ongoing
looking at things the other thing that's
changing is not only is Oregon getting C
cos I can't find a state who's not
trying to follow the Oregon model and it
is really a cool model so you guys
should take great pride in this but it's
also an unknown the the good news of
being the leader is your leader the bad
news of being the leader nobody's done
it before you so there is no right
answer you can't do a comparison that
say were they successful by the old
standards because your whole goal was
not to meet the old standards so how do
you set the standards in the bars for
what you're evaluating and think about
organ such a great place to look at
because you've got the Medicaid moving
to its CCOs its state employees are
eventually going to go to that but you
also got the health insurance exchanges
that are creating qualified health plans
not the same not the same requirements
and maybe not the same network and maybe
not the same players or some overlap but
not totally for doing it and a qualified
health plan not a term we use more than
two years ago and in Medicaid we don't
talk about a gold platinum silver and
I've got them in the wrong order comes
up later levels but in the new world of
health insurance exchanges those are
different levels of plans and there's
different parameters about each one of
those so understanding the variation you
know once you understand what each
bucket is you can figure out how to
relate the buckets to each other but
there is no consistency between the
buckets so it makes it an interesting
time at the same time you have a huge
initiative and I've had one on health
homes which is another way of looking at
it in kind of the traditional
fee-for-service market rather than a
full managed care plan of creating a
health home for people who are
chronically illness chronic illness also
including people with serious and
persistent mental illness and substance
abuse issues as well which we haven't
traditionally thought of them as having
a health hole but again if you remember
we've redefined health so it totally
makes sense but as a result of that you
have again a bunch of new entities their
payment methodologies are very different
in some of these models the idea of a
claim does not exist so if your data
source has always been for the financial
aspect
or even utilization was a claim over the
years your data source is going away
think prenatal care both private market
and Medicaid years ago we paid for every
visit and the hospital stay and we could
count on how many prenatal what premal
care you actually got it wasn't that
many years ago maybe six to eight years
ago we decided that the better way to
pay for prenatal care was in a global
budget bundle payment is the way we
called it and the idea was that if he
made the doctors at risk for the
delivery they would incentivize I would
be incentivized to get you to come in
and that I would look at the quality of
what you were getting and identify
things earlier because that would mean I
wouldn't have to do a c-section and that
I could do an easier delivery and have
less cost in the hospital which is
exactly what we want from a policy
perspective but I no longer know if you
had one visitor 14 visits because i
don't have episodes of care which is why
moving to the new world of electronic
health records were giving clinical data
on what actually happens in the clinic
in the hospital becomes a new data
source which means your role becomes
even more important because it actually
is looking at real clinical data it's
not looking at claims data does not mean
that claims that it totally goes away or
that it doesn't play an important role
because you also have an old payer
claims database here which has a lot of
historical data and you're not going to
have electronic health records aren't
going to go back to my birth there's no
doctor although that would do that maybe
if my grand childhood sangmin sold yeah
he's been on electronic health record
from day one because I wouldn't let his
parents go to a doctor that did not have
electronic health records not going to a
hospital that doesn't have those things
but that's my bias going into that so he
will have one his entire lifestyle none
of us are going to have one for our
entire life cycles because they weren't
existing at some of those are you that
may have been involved with Kaiser over
the years probably have more of a one
than others but outside of that it
doesn't exist so claims data is never
going away as a piece of the information
but it's no longer going to be the
information and then the others new
benefits and this is my favorite one
even Medicaid didn't pay for
habilitative
cepted home and community-based waivers
for individuals with developmental
disabilities it is now a new core
benefit it still needs to be defined it
still needs to do it but it's going to
be the private market it's going to be
in the public market and so there are
things like that just my example is
that's an easy one because it didn't
exist but other things like care that
impacts help what does that mean and
what gets covered and again as we do
these different payment models the
incentive is to do that there's a whole
debate going on scope of work on if aid
it's between dentists and dental high
notes for years on what could dental
hygienists do versus what kind of
dentists do for doing those discussions
are coming up in a lot of areas
telehealth is going to be another
interesting area that people are
starting to look at because we used to
think of that is our issue for the rural
area it is now a very urban area issue
because telehealth with new electronic
believe frog group guys know who the
leapfrog groups are private you know
okay so one of their three priorities
were intensive us which is that we have
a specialist like a hospitalist and the
icu's because of the specialty of the
care that's doing there even in very
urban areas each hospital in a lot of
places can't afford an intensive us so
what they have set up is an intensivist
in one of three hospitals with all the
technology built around them that they
are in a sense in the ICU in more than
one Hospital of time so that's bringing
telehealth to the very urban center is
in ways that we it's not a consult in
the way of doing it telemedicine is kind
of what we used to think about think
about telehealth now in the new
environment where we're really talking
about technology doing the home
monitoring because it is not a consult
it is about I go to my computer system
in the morning and I hook up but I do my
blood pressure up sup and it runs all
the data nobody interfaces with me it
runs all the data and it runs too
hopefully you're my doctor it runs to
you or a designated place that's a whole
policy debate talk about it policy
question is a durable is the home
monitoring equipment durable medical
equipment that
we treat like a wheelchair or is it a
physician service because it's another
value unless a physician or nurse
actually reads it reads it well but the
idea of that telehealth in that case is
not person-to-person consultant it's
person to machine and machine-to-machine
so we've even redefined what telehealth
is all about and looking at it very
differently my point is those are and do
numbers very well but the point is all
those variables are changing and there
are great opportunities to look at
things from a policy perspective Lee
very differently but they also make it
harder to do an evaluation on them
because they people want to know on the
accountability you know were there
program integrity issues were there
quality issues were their financial
issues think about the way we normally
do program integrity is anybody work in
the world of program integrity we tend
to look for the deviant that if all of
the people on this side of the room saw
ten people a day and all of a sudden you
showed up with 30 I go yeah right that
doesn't look right I need to look at
that right the data would tell me 30 is
a deviant okay look at all the variables
I change 30 might be the right answer
and none of you are going to have the
same number to start out with because
we're in a transition so how do you do
program integrity oversight in an
environment when we don't really know
what the right answer is and what we do
know is probably the answer we have
today isn't the exact right answer so
looking for that deviant isn't going to
work so it's a good question for
somebody to answer you can find a
contract if you undo that one this is
actually organs picture because I want
to bring it back home for you guys of
thinking future but how many things are
changing this is just their health
information exchange and it's a draft
they have a whole set of work group that
I've been meeting with that it's trying
to deal with concretely conceptually we
all want something different what does
it take to do that when do we do that
how do we do that what's okay what risk
are we really willing to take if you
start with today there is some
technology that's in place you guys do
direct secure messaging you guys know
what direct secure messaging anyway
and that environment allows exchange of
information now between hospitals and
doctors there's a whole debate between
with the electronic health record having
even affects capability within it is
there an advantage to go to a secure
electronic exchange I would still argue
yes but there is a debate about that but
in the world of healthcare delivery it's
not just about physicians in hospitals
it's about physicians being able to talk
to the nursing home the hospital talking
to the nurse home to transition them out
into the nursing home care from the
hospital it is about the hospital
talking to the home health they're not
going to have the formalize electronic
health records right away so the direct
secure messaging is a tool to
communicate securely and privately with
those entities that need to be part of
the healthcare system but they aren't
going to have the full-blown electronic
health records at least not in the near
future and you guys have a tool that
does that you also got to figure out
who's going to make the decisions
because we're creating these new
entities there wasn't a health
information exchange before because it
didn't exist there were regional health
information exchanges because they
didn't exist there were in health
insurance exchanges every state has to
figure out what that new entity is and
when and how you regulate it it's kind
of like moving to the world of HMOs and
managed care when they didn't exist they
weren't regulated but the second they
started to be there's consumer on needs
and security and privacy and just care
that you don't want entities operating
with the state that are not regulated by
anybody something bad could happen so
part of the debate right now in every
state including yours is to figure out
if there is an infrastructure to create
the highway what is that highway what
does it look like what does the state
provide to its constituent what do
providers provide what do other entities
provide and how do the pieces fit
together and if you think you guys have
it but in DC they reference the Beltway
around the DC and everybody gets on it
for different reasons but you have the
on ropes ramps so think of you as a
provider you want the on-ramp to get on
to the highway and sometimes you're
going to go in public transportation
sometimes you're going to drive your own
car and sometimes you're going to go
visit family
and sometimes you can go the doctor's
office you don't want to have different
unwraps that I go to a if I'm going on a
vacation and I go to be if I'm going to
the doctor it's one on ramp and that's
the highway that you're trying to build
for the world of information that
creates the data that they can be done
for analytics on the back end but also
creates the ability to deliver care much
more effectively and efficiently so you
guys are at this first stage what you're
talking about right now and so is every
state which is what are you doing in the
next two years you know what are the
pain point with all the things going on
that have to be in place to be able to
transform the healthcare delivery to do
that outer circle that was on the big
one and your priority are some
foundational things provider directories
think about in the world of electronic i
know because i would get it from you I
may know your phone number I may know
your mailbox address for snail mail
that's how we communicate it or your fax
number if we're going to do things
electronic I need to know your
electronic address and I certainly don't
want to have to call you or get ahold of
you and get your address and get a hold
a year and as a hospital they certainly
don't want to get asked every physician
for theirs but there has to be a way to
collect those new e addresses will call
them for doing it so you can communicate
with each other you want to be able to
do referrals back and forth but you
don't want the provider to have to
figure out and call somebody and say
okay I need to send a referral to you
you know what your address so the state
is looking about the tools that you
would need and just like you need a
phone look in the new world you need a
phone book but it's an electronic
address kind of thing and then a patient
index biggest national public policy
issue if it ever gets sorted out all the
happy camper for some reason we think
it's not okay to have an identity about
us although we all have social security
numbers but that aside we don't want a
patient ID however if you really think
about it because healthcare is clinical
there is a patrician mctaggart in Iowa
I've never met her but she is diabetic I
am NOT diabetic but we are the same age
and have the same name I do not want her
clinical records mixed up with mine and
I don't go to Iowa very often but you
know I travel everywhere so odds are
we'll be in iowa and
a couple years for some reason that's
where it takes a bigger different change
it's one thing to worry about it a
non-clinical not direct crystal thing
but when you get to that level and get
to the emergency room I want them to
know everything they can possibly know
about me as quickly as possible because
I want to come out alive right so the
fact that when i was young i went by
patti don't ask me why and then i was
Trish then I was Trisha and I'm Patricia
I would get the emergency room at the
time that I went into it has whatever
variation I was at the time including my
primary name so I want the ability to
bring that together what we have tended
to say right now is there is at least
five to seven variables we put together
and that says we're the same person
that's a lot of work and it's hardware
crosswalk internal time we're spending
thousands of millions of dollars with
vendors cross walking it every time we
do things so the big national policy
debate is how do you deal with consumers
fear of Big Brother and the ability to
get to add an identifier that helps us
in a clinical health care perspective to
make it easy to get the right
information on the right time and the
state also is trying to sort that out
for Oregon because quite frankly the
five elements of people usually say if
if you've ever worked with a Hmong
population it doesn't work because
especially if they've come over from
Vietnam a lot of the families have
multiple wives it's not legal the United
States so they all picked well at least
in Minnesota they all picked January 1st
is at birth date they have five people
with the same name they didn't have a
birthday so they picked the same birth
date they don't have social security
numbers so all the variables in certain
populations that we traditionally say
would make me stand out from you except
for sex don't work in those populations
so we kind of hit the point that was
okay for eligibility to take that risk
but when we're talking about do we give
them insulin or not it takes it to a
whole thing so that's clearly a message
for doing it and then creating the
highway for doing it hospitals
particularly those in this area but i
would say everywhere are talking about
the need for notifications and alerts
this is the idea that if i'm a primary
care doctor
you're in the emergency room the only
way we're going to get you better care
and follow-up is to have an alert that
they've had an ER visit it also is the
ability for yard have more data about
you so those are kind of high priority
things for people because we have to do
accountability clinical quality metrics
is the accountability metrics did you
improve health care so a lot of
discussion about creating a state
clinical quality registry and then I
really give you guys credits for this
one technical assistance providers I
don't hear that in a lot of other states
and it's critical on what we know in
Florida and I'm not picking on for it
it's just where the data is from the
business coalition of Health get rid of
them they are a private porn it's kind
of like the leapfrog group that has been
working on quality things for a very
long time they were working with their
doctors and I'm back a few years for
doing this but they really started
looking at quality data and the doctor
said your data is wrong so they started
feeding it back to them and then started
to do an analysis and doctors all
thanked not unfairly that they are in
the 98th percentile they wouldn't be
doing it if they didn't believe they
would 98th percentile but the data
showed is they were in 98 percentile
what the actions they were doing today
based on the day they went through
residency because when are you most
intense in this when is it most straight
and but unfortunately if you're 62 years
old you weren't residency last year well
might have been but most people were not
for doing it so the physicians
perception was correct they were doing
the scope of practice at the 98th
percentile or the hundred percent tell
of what they were supposed to be doing
unfortunately we keep changing medicine
and everything and don't keep it up to
him so getting that information flow
giving them the best tools so they can
use them means that's an opportunity to
improve health care but it has to work
for them i T is not about creating the
IT system and getting everybody to
adjust to it it's a creating the IT
system that has the workflow needs
that's sad you cannot create IT to meet
a paper put world paper world or we
haven't changed healthcare delivery oh
just because we did it a certain way for
workflow because we had to follow the
paper and I don't know if you guys know
the story but my favor
went for CPOE there was a big article on
Massachusetts hospital where they
actually had showed they had more
medical errors after they put in CPOE
did you read the rest of the story of
how they implemented it the doctors
didn't like implementing it so the
doctors circumvented and han wrote the
orders and gave them to the nurses who
took him to the front desk and then put
it in the CPOE system heey kind of think
it kind of kind of messed up the purpose
so all the things they were supposed to
fix like handwriting didn't get fixed so
implementation is a critical piece and
peace people are looking at it and then
you guys are talking about you know 2015
because what do we know about i.t
anything you start today will barely be
in place by 2015 so it's again thinking
ahead and if you're going to try and do
any analysis in Oregon did I not say
your world's changing when you're going
to try and do it all of these factors
will be in place and 20 other things
haven't figured and health insurance
exchanges for doing it and there's
variation of ways of doing it I have to
tell you Minnesota I am for Minnesota it
still got the favorite commercials that
I have I the Paul Bunyan ones I think
are stitched for doing it but that's
just because I'm from Minnesota in my
life Paul Bunyan but you got hair Oregon
you guys are operating the state
insurance exchanges there are other
states that are doing a federal
partnership and other states where the
feds are doing itself there is not a
state where there's not a health
insurance exchange by definition they
all went live this week somehow there is
also when you implement anything there
is always glitches if you think this was
bad there's no way you could have
predicted it but I said this with
Medicare Part D who would implement
something for elderly and disabled on a
holiday that was a Sunday that's when we
implemented Medicare Part D think about
that pharmacy when do you get your
pharmaceuticals when you're in elderly
on the first of the month so they went
to a new program to go in to a pharmacy
on a holiday to try and get something
that they never had before that the
pharmacists were also trying to transfer
the only thing that up does add is
putting a government shutdown on the day
that you're trying to implement a health
insurance exam you know I said they
could now do it and I was wrong tell you
is why I shouldn't predict anything
right but even in a state that says it's
not in our state
in our state and because it is your
insurance it affects every provider in
the state because it is in your state
and it has to have that single
application with the Medicaid it affects
all the Medicaid and the state programs
so it doesn't matter if you have a
federal one in your state or state-run
state it is in the state and it has to
integrate with the health care delivery
system and it has to integrate with the
other insurance coverage systems in the
state the partnership ones are just
really interesting I won't spend much
time on it go it's not you guys but it's
really intriguing there were states that
get really smart and said you know
Oregon figured out a long time ago and
said we're going to do this so they
started working on it other states kind
of dug their head in the sands or spend
a lot of time thinking about it and then
said I want to do it well what did I say
about IT there's nothing you can do that
quickly you cannot six months ago decide
you want to help a health insurance
exchange it ain't going to happen but
what the federal government did with
them is we will partner and what the
states did is those things that it work
most close to that regulate the
qualified health plans they regulate
health funds all the time something very
close to their hearts and consumer
engagement kinds of activities something
that again is very local navigators and
things like that so the plan management
the consumer assistance in those states
and they all have plans to have more
state takeover of the operation of the
health insurance exchange but in a plan
that where they can get to it in a way
that they can effectively get it done at
the infrastructure in place for doing it
questions about the health insurance
exchanges and you can look at every
paper everywhere on what's going on with
that one and it also new options and
this is the part I think is important in
service delivery because we now have to
figure out how we oversight them and how
we do that there is tell Emma Jean there
is texting it's also starting to look at
the telephone and using those things
different the traditional file sharing
through the internet remote health
monitoring video conferencing in the
world of behavioral health skype blogs
email secure once hopefully and here are
the new data systems that new
opportunities for data sources for doing
and in the first column it is the
clinical data sources that we didn't
have before second column are more the
claims third our surveys and
administrative data cap surveys you guys
have cami you have other things like
that you're also going to do some for
your ccos administrative data we can't
forget that's a huge piece of
information like I said in the health
insurance exchanges and the whole world
of public health data these now because
of the health information exchanges and
States will be connected before trying
to get data from those across was just
impossible because they were all silos
now over the next couple years they will
be able to be connected through various
variations with each other and allow
data to flow the other thing that's
happening is all these new tools are
being overlaid that are the analytics
that the ability to do data warehouses
to provide a proto consumer portals on
provider directory but all those tools
lay on top that allow you to take the
data out so it's the ability to collect
the data to ingest the data to analyze
the data and disseminate the data and
then the dissemination they're all kinds
of new outputs that are coming out and
the real difference is where as it's
going to it is now about feeding it back
to providers at the same time we feed it
to regulators as we type and the whole
world of consumer engagement is we also
feed it back to consumers so they can be
an engaged party to this my point of
this slide and I know it looks busy is
we have to start thinking bigger we've
thought about a data source and right
now a data source is not what we're
about it is about information that is
collected from multiple sources how
they're put together how they're
analyzed and then how they're used to
serve the verses and so what's changed
what not the funny models have changed
we talked about the contracts the reason
to engage people are looking to you as
the experts and so you need to be a part
of the engagement we have a huge need in
a gap that needs to be filled and it
needs to be filled by you guys and
there's more than enough work if you're
willing to do it and the benefit from
engaging um there is not only and I say
this to my grad students a lot but it's
true and I think we forget this by
leading in the research we gain
knowledge and gaining that knowledge and
be
able to apply to something that you're
very good at and that is something that
is being really really missed and that's
where the contracts and the grants are
really being requested is that
translation and that utilization and the
more you're seeing is that credible
leader the more you'll be able to leave
and I I think you get to use this time
to really maximize that and fully
utilize that and bring your expertise to
the table and let's see I don't know
that I do much on this data sources we
talked about that think differently
about data collection data content but
we'll get a lot of new data sources
we're going to have to be very clear
about which ones aligned which ones
don't how old what's a source of truth
for dates and things like that and then
the IT infrastructure and the
specifications to do that those are all
needed in order to do what we just
talked about doing it they're pretty
boring and they're pretty basic but they
are the critical pieces for moving
forward and then format interfaces and
then governance and I talked about the
source of truth but it's really
understanding also some of the
limitations of the data and the
opportunities as we move forward and
this one is really become a hot issue
for pre and post there is a lot of data
now that's outside of the claims data
that we haven't collected and now the
expectation is that we have that inside
our information and that's a new one for
something to figure out how to make that
one work because it's really going to be
difficult and then as I said we've
created the health insurance exchanges
that didn't define anything the same way
as anybody else challenges for you and
for everybody else is interoperability a
word I didn't say three years ago and
now I say probably every two hours and
that means the ability to not only send
data and get it back but to be able to
be understood the same way going as it
is coming the fact that a structured
data is only twenty percent of the
healthcare data so how do you really
analyze non structured data privacy will
always be a big issue in order to have
privacy you get a deal with security and
then quite frankly keeping up with a
change of pace because it's going to
keep changing
and welcome to health care it never bet
it whoops those down and these are just
all the different things that are going
on at once to Jason McNamara's friend of
mine at CMS those are all the things he
identified that will change why you're
trying to do anything that will affect
your data sources and public health has
become a new part of this and how states
are going to deal with that is going to
be critical for you and for everybody
that's a piece that has been outside the
market and it's now inside the market
and an expectation that we have the data
one of the things that CDC put out
literally on October second is a notice
to all state Public Health they have the
systems to identify and do alerts they
are closed down so states are going to
have to pick that up while we have the
furlough state infrastructure's it
because of those kinds of things because
of Sandy and all the kinds of issues
that we've had in the last couple years
natural and man-made the role of states
and the data is going to be important
because it's got to be a part of the
healthcare delivery system it's not the
reporting it is service delivery and
cost you know money is always a big
issue for doing it and this is just my
favorite way to end what to avoid too
much information and too little
knowledge because we're going to have a
lot of data potentially hopefully a lot
of information but if we can't change it
into knowledge it doesn't do anybody any
good and I tried to rush the end to give
us a few minutes to ask questions since
nobody was asking in the process for
doing it and yeah i am from Minnesota
and I do talk fast hopefully we hit on a
few things that were of interest to
people any comments or just a reminder
that I forgot use the button when you
asked your question or make a comment
could we talk about a national patient
identifier just for a minute and I know
it's taboo talking about that within the
federal government but I had heard there
was a private sector effort to work on
that
and I wondered if you could give us an
update on what might be happening
actually it's the federal Congress
actually said to HHS that you cannot
spend any money or spend any time on
anything that goes near this subject
much to my surprise the [ __ ] ook gives
notifier group is there Federal Advisory
Committee has 40 NC office enough
coordinator which is hHS has now taken
up the issue of a single identifier
because it came from everybody and I was
a part of the group that was doing the
national effort all the organizations
are doing and our proposal to Congress
was let's get an IOM study to tell ONC
that they have to do it now how silly is
that but that was the only way we could
figure out of getting it done since HHS
said doesn't matter if we agree with you
totally we can't touch it for doing it
but they have at least their legal
advisers are taking a very liberal view
of a fokker group could do that and
that's not really HHS spending more
money on it not sure how they're making
that work but I think the question is
how we do it because there's nobody
anymore who says we shouldn't be doing
it but there is a consumer advocacy
group and there's a lady who's on the
hill every day and it's her mon turrets
or full-time job that this is about the
government this is about Big Brother you
know California had trouble with the
immunization registry for years because
the perception was it was a tipping
point if you let their have an
identifier there which they needed in
order to do their immunization registry
it would just be a snowball and it would
just keep going so I think we are in a
position where the clinical need
outweighs the perceived concerns of the
past but it's a tough road uphill and
with this Congress getting their
attention right now and that probably
won't be high but I will tell you with
in DC that's how we get some things done
is get IOM to do a study that will say
everything you you already know but
somehow if they say it it makes it legit
then I was just going to kind of
piggyback on that is there any talk
about standardizations across platforms
yes and with the Office of National
Coordinator the CMS does the
standardization for quality metrics and
for meaningful use incentive payments
but the office the National Coordinator
is the home for standardization for
electronic health records they're now
talking about standardization for health
information exchange that they set the
standards for doing it this is the
balancing act I and I have a bias here I
will tell you that I believe
standardization is more efficient and
more effective and it's like driving the
car I don't really care what the signs
look like just make sure I understand
what the signs are and hopefully most of
the time I will comply with them just
give me enough notice though you know
Marilyn seat belts in the back seats
when october first they notified the
world i have no excuse for not knowing
that but i don't think that's something
we should vary I think that is a
standard that we do it and I think the
information on highways the same thing I
think it is it's like Microsoft there's
nothing worse than switching between
Microsoft and Apple because you're going
through two different standards that is
true in the healthcare world and we have
enough confusion we don't need to add to
it and we want this to be easy for
providers and they will be better off
the standard but the real debate is is
really a triangle and I love this one
it's not mine it's actually somebody
here came up with it which is what's you
centralize what do you standardize and
what you will align if you think in that
kind of model what you centralize are
the things that are the regulations that
they are statewide for doing what you
standardize is it doesn't matter a
provider a or provider be are doing it
these are the standards it's like an
icd-10 it makes her like we hey-hate
transfer in German icd-9 to icd-10 but
we all get why there's a value of doing
icd-10 this in the world of electronic
that is just to me core and a lining is
how you implement it you want you may
want some ability that Dennis don't have
to put everything in the doctor does
because they don't do the same thing but
where they put it in and how the
format's of what they put it in and what
it means you want to be the state so
that's where standardization align for
doing it to me its core it is very hard
in a market that wants to balance
marketplace and local initiatives with
state and federal
determination it's just a hard one
providers also have a little concern
about what they call cookbook medicine
but that's not we're talking about we're
not telling them how to do it we're
trying to create standardized tools that
can do it because one thing that we have
found already is alert fatigue you know
if your phone beeps all the time you
just turn it off right there is a
certain point of what you do that the
trouble with alerts is that if I'm in
your office and I'm starting next to a
cardiac and I'm diabetic you doin I do
not want you doing Mike foot exam and
doing those things but you alerts will
do that if they're not prioritized in
that hierarchy to them if I'm a diabetic
and I'm in the doctor's office if he
doesn't check looking at him but or she
doesn't check it's going to hit an alert
before we try to go out but if the
overriding reason I'm in there is it
looks like I'm having a heart attack I
don't really care about my diabetic care
right down and neither does the doctors
so we've got a the trouble with the
industry is the IT industry is also
evolving and we've almost built this
expectation that they're here now kind
of that chart of where they're going we
are at meaningful use stage 1 today's
everybody understands stage 1 there are
certain requirements but it doesn't even
require the electronic exchange of
information requires testing it doesn't
require exchange that's meaningful use
stage 2 2014 only if your hospital is
this now 2014 because they're on fiscal
year but for everybody else that's
January like the rest of us for doing it
so even those standards that the vendors
had to build to don't go in place and
all your vendors are rolling them out as
we speak right now sadly it's turning
out to be summer and fall when there by
the time they got the information of
what they had to do they created it
they're implementing it I don't know
we're always at you is but your hospital
must be putting in its new meaningful
used to or maybe it has it in right now
I don't know but it would be now that it
would be doing it so part of it is that
new technology wasn't there and what do
we also know about did anybody get the
new microsoft that didn't work the
trouble with new technology is sometimes
if you're the first one doing it
don't work and my husband is one of
those that the second it's on the shelf
he's got it I'm one of those if it's on
the shelf in six months then I'll go buy
it because then it's probably working in
somebody else tried it that's where
doctors I think about small physicians
they don't want to try anything that's
you I my favorite course I get from the
in the college I tell me which one to
get you know i'm not going to go ask for
it twice so that's the problem orion for
doing it and I'm over time so I'm going
to shut up thank you